كنيسه الاسرائيليه الثقه للحكومه الجديده
برئاسه بنيامين نتنياهو المؤلفه من حزب
اللكود واحزاب اقصى اليمين من الصهيونيه
الدينيه واحزاب المتزمطين اليهود وكان
الائتلاف الجديد قدم للكنيسه وثيقه الخطوط
العريضه لحكمته وابرز بنودها ما سمي
احاقيه اليهود بكامل اراضي فلسطين
التاريخيه وتعزيز الاستيطان في الضفه
والجوله
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الاعزاء كنا ذاك خبر
حلقتنا ولنا في نقاش ثلاثه مسارات ما الذي
يمكن ان نقراه في تشكيله الحكومه
الاسرائيليه الجديده وفي ملامح البرنامج
الذي تعيد بتطبيقه خلال فتره ولايتها
وما فرص نجاحي هذا التشكيل الاكثر يمنيه
وتطرفا في اسرائيل في تسويق نفسه داخليا
في اسرائيل وعلى مستوى الاقليم والمجتمع
الدولي
وما هي خيارات الفلسطينيين للتعامل مع
الحكومه الاسرائيليه الجديده وما مصير
ملفات الامن والاسرى والاستيطان والسلام
في الفتره المقبله
[موسيقى]
باغلبيه 63 عضوا ينتمون لحزب اللكود
الحاكم واحزاب اقصى اليمين من الصهيونيه
الدينيه واحزاب المتزنتين اليهود منح
الكنيسه الاسرائيلي المؤلف من 120 عضوا
الثقه للحكومه الاكثر يمنيه في تاريخ
اسرائيل
الحكومه الجديده التي يراسها بنيامين
نتنياهو كانت قد قدمت وثيقه الخطوط
العريضه لبرنامجها وابرز بندهم سمي احاطيه
اليهود في كامل لاراضي فلسطين التاريخيه
وتعزيز الاستيطان وتوسيعه في الضفه
الغربيه وهضبه الجولان كما اكد رئيسها
ايضا حرص حكومه على احباط مساعي ايران
لتطوير سلاح النووي يهدد اسرائيل وقد يقود
انها كما قال واكد انها ستوقع مزيدا
اتفاقيات السلام خلال الفتره المقبله وان
وزير دفاعيه سيكون مسؤولا عن تنسيق الشؤون
من منطقه الضفه الغربيه
[موسيقى]
بمناسبه هذا الموضوع معنى من رام الله
الدكتور مصطفى البرغوثي الامين العام
للمبادره الوطنيه الفلسطينيه ومن الخليل
عادل شديد الباحث المختص في الشؤون
الاسرائيليه ومعك السيد عادل نبدا اذا كان
من المتوقع ان يمنح الكنيسه الثقه لحكومه
بنيامين نتنياهو التي توصف بانها الاكثر
يمنيه والاكثر تزمتا والاكثر تشددا في
اسرائيل لكن الان وقد اصبح الامر واقعا في
ثنايا هذه الحكومه ما الذي تقراه وتستشرفه
للمستقبل من خلال عملها المتوقع
مساء الخير لك استاذ حسن وللجزيره ولضيفك
دكتور مصطفى البرغوثي
ولكافه المشاهدين
طبيعي انه حكومه كهذه واللي
بالضم
بمركباتها مجموعه من القوى صاحبه المشاريع
التي تمزج ما بين الفحم الدين التوراه مع
الفهم القومي الصهيوني
واضح تماما انه لن تكون اسرائيل بعد هذا
اليوم كما كانت اسرائيل قابلها سواء
بالعلاقه معنى الفلسطينيين او مع شرائح
واسعه من المجتمع اليهودي وتحديدا شريحه
اليهود الاشكناز الغربيين اصحاب القيم
الليبراليه الديمقراطيه ولا وحتى مع مع
مجموعه يعني الدول الاوروبيه ويهود الشتاء
نحن كفلسطينيين كما بدات حديثك انه اولى
برامج هي الحكومه انه للشعب اليهودي لم
يقل انه للمجتمع اليهودي في اسرائيل او
للاسرائيليين قال للشعب اليهودي يعني لكل
يهودي العالم الحق الحصري في كل ارض
اسرائيل التاريخيه بمعنى انه منح انه
البلاد فلسطين التاريخيه كانها حق حصري
وحيد ل يهودي العالم ان استنادا الى روايه
الثمار بين كبير وستروك ومعوز همم اللي
بيشكله اهم مركبات هاي الحكومه وهذا يعني
الغاء كامله فلسطين الغاء تام الى الشعب
الفلسطيني
واللي ايضا باقي مواد همم برنامج الحكومه
السياسي والايدلوجي ضم الكثير من العناصر
اللي لها علاقه بالغاء الوجود الفلسطيني
طيب سواءا بالخليل بالقدس باللقب بالجليل
بالجولان بمعنى انه انه يراد من هاي
الحكومه
استغلال وجودها لترجمه هذا المشروع
التوراه العقائد القومي بالغاء وطمس كل ما
هو فلسطيني
الى التساؤل عن ان كانت هذه الحكومه هي
الاكثر وضوحا في تاريخ اسرائيل دكتور
مصطفى البرغوثي في هذا الاطار سمنه من يرى
بان همم
اسرائيل او الحكومات السابقه كانت تتبنى
هذه المشاريع ولكن لم تكن تعلن عنها
بصراحه
المختلف هذه المره ان هذه الحكومه اظهرت
وجهها الحقيقي او وجه اسرائيل الحقيقي او
وجوه الحكومات السابقه
وتعلن على الملاء ولن يتغير شيء ما رايك
لم يتغير شيء من حيث انه جميع الحكومات
السابقه كانت عنصريه متطرفه ولكن تغير شيء
كثير لانه الواقع الذي كشف وجهه الحقيقي
هو الحركه الصهيونيه كل هذه الحكومات هي
اا ابناء همم او همم يعني تشكل امتدادا
للحركه الصهيونيه
والحركه الصهيونيه الان تشعر بقوه وتشعر
انها تستطيع ان تكشف اوراقها بشكل كامل
واا تظهر عاريه الان
بينواياها ومقاصدها لكن هذه الحكومه الاشد
عنصريه والاكثر تطرفا وهي حكومي اصوليه
وفاشيه وتضم فاشين بشكل واضح وايضا حكومه
اجراميه بمعنى انها على استعداد لتدمير
حقوق الانسان بشكل كامل فلسطيني وايضا خلق
القانون الدولي بكل اشكاله ولها
الميزه فيما يجري انها واضحه تماما في
خمسه محاور بسرعه فقط
بشكل غير مقصود وكانك تبرا الحكومات
السابقه من هذه الافعال وهو ما كانت
الحكومات السابقه ايضا متهمه بها اكان على
مستوى قتل الفلسطينيين او خرق القانون
الدولي وحتى على مستوى الاستيطان
بالعكس انا اقول عكس ذلك لا ابرئ الحكومات
بل اؤكد انها كانت طوال الوقت حكومات
عنصريه اجراميه ولكن الذي تراه اليوم هو
التطور الطبيعي للحركه الصهيونيه التي
بدات باخفاء نفسها ولم تظهر نواياها
ومقاصدها بضم كل فلسطين اليوم هي تظهر
عاريه كالشمس وتؤكد ان المسار اللي صارت
في كل الحكومات السابقه منذ عام 48 وحتى
اليوم هو نفس المسار والان وصل الى مستوى
في التطور متقدم بحيث يتجرا نتنه ان يعلن
ان اطار هذه الحكومه وسياساتها موجهه اولا
لضم الضفه الغربيه ضمه الغربيه بالكامل
ثانيا توسيع المستوطنات بشكل كامل مش بس
في الضفه الغربيه وفي الجليل والمثلث
والنقب والجولان وثا هو يتحدث عن انه
توسيع المستوطنات هو هو امر يعني اولويه
كبرى لهذه الحكومه واضف الى ذلك ما ذكر
بانه يقولوا ان فلسطين بكاملها حلها فيها
حق حصري احتكار كامل لليهود لليهود بشكل
كامل ولا مكان للفلسطينيين نحن نتحدث هنا
عن اعلان
نيه التطهير العرقي واعلان نيه الضم
والتهويد الكامل واضف الى ذلك انه كل هذه
العمليه التي تمس اهلنا في الداخل مثل ما
تمس اهل الضفه الغربيه وغزه والقدس
والجلان هل تكرر نظام الابر تايد العنصري
الاجرامي بالكامل طيب همم يعني امام هذا
البرنامج همم السيد عادل الجديد هل بامكان
هذه الحكومه اليمنيه الاسرائيليه المتطرفه
بهذا الشكل مع هذا البرنامج ان تسوق نفسها
كان داخليا او حتى خارجيا هل سيكون الامر
باليسر ربما الذي كانت عليه الحكومات
السابقه التي كانت تخفي مقاصدها بعناوين
يقبلها المجتمع الدولي او حتى
المجتمع الداخلي الاسرائيلي
يعني اعتقد انه
الايجابي على هذا السؤال
قد يختلف في القارئ للشان الاسرائيلي من
الداخل ومن داخل العقل الاسرائيلي الي
بفكر للصهيوني الدينيه هم لا
يعني يعتبرون او لا يعطون اهميه للاعتراف
الدولي او الخارجي في اسرائيل يعني مقوله
هيرسل وبنغوليون انه يجب ان نكون جزء من
الحضاره الغربيه بالشرق الاوسط وان نحظه
على دعم دول هاي المجموعه لا يعنيها كثيرا
جماعه ايتمار بن كزير
العظمه اليهوديه
واشتراك جماعه همم
الصهيوني الدينيه مؤمنين عقائديا انه
اولويتهم ارضاع ربنا وليس ارضاع للكافر
اللي هم شريحه واسعه من اليهود الغربيين
في منطقه تل ابيب
وسط والمركز او
الاوروبيين او الامريكان يعني بمعنى لا
يابهون كثيرا ان تنقبول هاي الدولي هاي
الحكومه ام لا ولا يسالون كثيرا لا بالعكس
ان بعضهم مؤمن عقائديا انه كلما رفضت هذه
الحكومه من الاغيار من غير اليهود اللي هم
بيكرهوا اسرائيل كلما تقربت هذه
الحكومه من التوراه ومن
النهجيرهم
وهو وهو الذي له باع طويل في رئاسه
الحكومه وفي التعامل مع الدول
يعني لا شك انه نتنياهو ينسجم باكثر من 90
بالمئه بالمواقف السياسيه اتجاه
الفلسطينيين مع حي المجموعه شركاء اليوم
جمعت بينكفير وجماعه سمو تريتش ويستروك
وهاي المجموعه ولكن يختلف معهم الى حد ما
برؤيتهم اتجاه المجتمع اليهودي يعني بمعنى
لما وزيره مستوطنه من الخليل تدعو الاطباء
وتحاول تضمينها في البرنامج ان الطبيب
اليهودي المتدين يوم السبت عليه ان يعالج
المريض اليهودي المتدين ولكن الممنوعا
عليه ان يمس بقدسيه الثابت وان يعالج غير
يهودي عربي او يهودي مش متدين مذكره
المثليين وحرمت ان يقوم طبيب يهودي متدين
يوم السبت من تقديم العلاج الطبي لا يهودي
مثل اذا وصل وكان مصاب او مريض او مشابه
بمعنى انه نحن امام حكومه تتبنى
منطق ثوراتي متطرف جدا لا تابى من التعبير
عنه حتى لو اغضبت ما اسموهم الاغياب لسبب
بسيط انهم مقتنعين تماما انه هذا الدعم
الامريكي وهذا الدعم الاوروبي لاسرائيل لم
يكن لولا ان اسرائيل قويه وقوه اسرائيل
تزداد من وجهه نظرهم كلما عادت الى
التوراه وعادت الى الى الجبل
يعتبرونها الهيه وليست
وضعيه همم الدنيويه هكذا يفكرون طيب ساعود
اليك لكن عفوا لكن في الاشاره هنا الى
انها متظاهرين اسرائيليين كانوا قد
استبقوا التصديق على حكومه نتنياهو
بالتظاهر ضدها امام الكنيست ويحتاج
المتغيرون على ما يسمونه تشكيل الحكومه
الاكثر تطرفا دينيا وراسيا واجتماعيا منذ
اقامه اسرائيل ويتم المحتجون نتنياهو
بالسعي للبقاء في السلطه من اجل حمايه
نفسه من المحاكمه في ق فساد المتهم بها
وكان ما يزيد عن مئات سفير ودبلوماسيه
اسرائيلي متقاعد بوزاره الخارجيه قد اعرب
يوم الاربعاء في مذكره ليله ياهو عن قلقهم
من امكانيه ان تلحق سياسه الحكومه التي
تشكلت ان تلحق الضرر بعلاقتك الاديب
الخارجيه واعرب السفراء الدبلوماسيون في
رسالتهم عن مخاوفهم من ان تؤدي التطورات
الاخيره في الساحه الداخليه الى رد دولي
قاسم والحاق الضرر بالعلاقات الاستراتيجيه
مع الولايات المتحده واوروبا وبتفاقات
ابراهام لتصنيع مع الامارات والبحرين والى
هذه خطوات ضد اسرائيل وحكومتها وجنودها
ومواطنيها في المحاكم الدوليه واكد
دبلوماسيون ان التغيرات والتطورات الاخيره
قد يكون لها تاثير كذلك في الوجود التجاري
الدولي والاستثمارات الاجنبيه في اسرائيل
كما انها ستؤثر بلا شك بحسب الدبلوماسيين
الاسرائيليين في القانوني المتوقع في
محكمه العدل الدوليه بشان الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي للاراضي الفلسطينيه والذي
وافقت الامم المتحده اشارا الماضي على طلب
فلسطينيين بالتماسه من محكمه العدل اعود
اليك دكتور مصطفى البرغوثي هنا في همم
الحديث عن هذه الحكومه
وعلاقاتها الدوليه كما تابعنا سفراء
اسرائيليون سابقون يخشون من ان تلحق هذه
الحكومه وادائها الضرر في علاقات اسرائيل
الخارجيه وهمم في الكثير من الامور التي
كانت يعني همم كانت اسرائيل
تحفظ الجانب الدولي
منه
لصالحها الان هل يمكن ان تؤثر فعلا هذه
الحكومه في العلاقات الدوليه في اتفاقات
ابراهام كما يقولون وفي الراي القانوني
للمحاكم الدوليه وغيرها
طبعا
بمقدارنا هذه الحكومه مجرمه ومتطرفه
وخطيره بمقدار ما هي ستؤدي الى امرين
الامر الاول مزيد من التفتت الداخلي في
اسرائيل
تفتت الداخلي مجتمعي وتفتت بين اطراف
مختلفه في داخل اسرائيل وهذا يسهل علينا
مهمه النضال ضدهم الامر الثاني الاهم ان
هذه فرصه لا تعوض غير مسبوقه لفرض العزله
والمقاطعه على اسرائيل تفضل العزله
والمقاطعه على هذه الحكومه المكشوفه بشكل
كامل كامل كان متطرفه عنصريه وكم منظومه
ابارتيد وتميز عنصري بالشكل الواضح
والكامل هذا يفتح لنا مجالات كبيره اذا ما
تبنا همم الفلسطينيون بكل مكوناتهم
استراتيجيه العزل والمحاصره امامنا فرصه
ضخمه لا تعوض واول الامثله على ذلك قرار
صندوق السياده النرويجي اللي هو اكبر واحد
من اكبر صناديق الاستثمار في العالم
بالياء واحد وثلاثه بالعشره ترليون دولار
قرر ان يعيد النظر في كل استثماراته في
اسرائيل امثله على ذلك كثير من الشركات
التي قررت ان توقف استثماراتها في اسرائيل
اذا امامنا فرصه لتصعيد حركه المقاطعه
وفرض العقوبات والعزله على هذه الحكومه
الاسرائيليه وبالمناسبه هذا اكثر شيء
يخشونه ولكن في موضوع التطبيق علينا ان
نرى ان واحد ان الاساس السادس الاستراتيجي
في حكومه نتنياهو وتوسيع التطبيع مع
المحيط العربي ومحاوله توسيع التطبيع بهدف
عزل وتصفيه القضيه الفلسطينيه لذلك بمقدار
ما نحن نسعى للمقاطعه على المستوى الدولي
ضد اسرائيل يجب ان يكون هناك حمل واسع على
الصعيد العربي لمحاصره ووقف هذا التطبيع
بل وسطه الى الوراء وفي هذا المجال هناك
فرص كبيره كما راينا في مظاهرات في المغرب
في 32 مدينه ضد التطبيع رايناها في مظاهره
في البحرين
راينا العظيم في الم
الدكتور هنا لابد من الاشاره الى ما ينقله
موقع اكسيوس عن البيت الابيض بانه يتطلع
الى العمل مع اسرائيل لتعزيز المصالح
والقيم التي كانت في صحيفه في صميم
علاقتنا لعقود كما يقول وااا ينقل ايضا عن
البيت الابيض تاييده لسياسات التي تعزز
امن اسرائيل وتكامل الاقليمي ودعم حل اا
الدولتين يعني همم الان هناك مواقف تصدر
من الجانب الامريكي الذي كان قال انه
سيحكم على الحكومه من افعالها وليس عبر
الشخصيات التي
بداخلها ساعود اليك في الحديث عن الجانب
الفلسطيني لكن سيد عادل همم شديد هل يمكن
ان همم تتبلور في ضوء المواقف الداخليه
الاسرائيليه ان تتبر- تتبلور معارضه
يمينيه اسرائيليه لحكومه نتنياهو الجديده
بعنوان الحفاظ على المصالح الدوليه
والخارجيه لاسرائيل استثمارات وغيرها
باختصار
يعني معارضه ياميليه يعني بالفحم اليميني
لا اعتقد ذلك لسبب بسيط انه هاي الحكومه
ثابته وقويه تحظى بتاييد ودعم 64 عضو
كنيست يهودي من احزاب اليمين المختلفه في
ظلموا معرضه حوالي 45 عضو كنيسه يهودي
سياسيا اكثريتهم ينتمون الى اليمين
اغلبيتهم ينتمون اليمين ولكن يعارضون هذه
الحكومه في جانبينز في نتنياهو ان يكون
رئيس حكومه وهو ملاحق للقضاء وفاسد واليه
درع كذلك الامر وما جابه ثم في مواقفه
اتجاه داخل اسرائيل اتجاه الحريات الفرديه
اتجاه الثابت علاقه الدين بالدوري لحم
الخنزير المثليين هاي القضايا ولكن اليوم
مع مع تاديه هذه الحكومه القسم وهمم
استماح الاول بالكنيسه كان في الاف اليهود
همم العلمانيين او ال- ال- وتحديدا
الغربيين المعارضين له الحكومه تظهروا
وكانوا بالالاف وهذا تطور مهم جدا ان يتم
تجنيد الاف اليهود من قبل 40 مؤسسين نظمت
لهذه الحركه ليس اا لمواقف الحكومه تجاه
القضيه الفلسطينيه انما نتيجه مواقفنا هلا
وين الخطوره من وجهه نظر اسرائيلي الحكومه
اليوم
خلقت انقسام انقسام كبير في المجتمع وهو
في الجيش اخطر ما في الموضوع انه بدات
تصدر دعوات مثلا انه الجنود العلمانيين لن
يقوموا بحمايه المستوطنين ولم يقوم بحمايه
الحي اليهودي في مدينه الخليل
البرنامج الحكومه تتضمن ماده واحده ماده
لتوسيع هذا الحقيقه وبالمقابل بالمقابل
مكونات ال- ال- الحكومه جماعه بني كبير
اخضع الجيش لفتاوي صوتنيا
هذا يجعلنا ايضا همم نتساءل في مرحله
لاحقه عن قدره صمود هذه الحكومه امام
ربما هذه التناقضات ولو ببعض القضايا التي
تعتبرها بعض الاحزاب في الحكومه الاساسيه
بالنسبه الي لكن لا وقت لدينا نود نسال
الدكتور مصطفى البرغوثي هنا عن الجانب
الفلسطيني كيف سيتعامل مع هذه الحكومه
يعني اذا كان العالم اذا كانت الدول
المتوجهه منها ماذا عن الجانب الفلسطيني
الرسمي وما هي خيارات الفلسطينيين في هذه
المرحله مع هذا البرنامج المتطرف باختصار
دكتور
باختصار بعد ان جاءت حكومه تعلن على من
انها ستضم الضفه الغربيه وهو طبعا يظهر
النفاق الامريكي اللي لسه بيحكوا عن حل
الدولتين وهم يرون اسرائيل تدمر حل الدوله
امام الفلسطينيين الان لم يعد هناك اي
مبرر على الاطلاق للاستمرار في التمسك
بالاتفاقيات البائسه اتفاق اوسلو وغيره
الذي دمرته اسرائيل بالكامل لم يبقى مبرر
لاستمرار تنسيق امني مع هذه الحكومه
الاسرائيليه الاجراميه ولم يبقى اي مبرر
للتقاعس عن توحيد الصف الوطني الفلسطيني
بسرعه على برنامج وطني الكفاحي مقاوم ما
حك جلدك مثل ظفرك ولا يوقف هؤلاء
المتطرفين الى نضال الشعب الفلسطيني
ومقاومته اولا وطبعا دعم اصدقاءنا ايضا
ولكن الامر الاهم ماذا سيفعله الفلسطينيون
والان انا اقول هناك فرصه تاريخيه لبناء
وحده نضاليه كفاحيه بين الفلسطينيين في
الداخل في الاراضي وفي الخارج لصد وتعريه
هذه الحكومه وفرض العزله عليها ولمقاومه
مخططاتها على الارض مقاطعتها وعزلها
بالاضافه الى توحيد القناه الثانيه على
برنامج وطني كفاحي مقاوم شكرا لك دكتور
مصطفى البرغوثي وشكرا ايضا
للباحث عادل همم شديد كان معنا من الخليل
انتهت حلقتنا من برنامج ما وراء الخبر الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]